[Música]
es que la primera vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales en colombia
dejó varios mensajes claros el debate
político ya no es entre el uribismo y el
petismo además el castigo al
establecimiento y el deseo de cambios
son evidentes vamos a hablar de la
victoria de petro y de hernández quien
sin duda fue el protagonista de la
jornada hablamos de este último de
hernández que con 5.1 de millones de
votos y el 28 por ciento de la votación
acaparó todas las miradas petro
consiguió por su parte un resultado
histórico para la izquierda con 8.5
millones de votos y el 40% de la
votación una primera vuelta nunca antes
un candidato de izquierda había liderado
la primera vuelta en colombia y no
podemos dejar un lado tampoco el fracaso
del derechista federico fico gutiérrez
que puede interpretarse como un castigo
al presidente saliente iván duque y
también al uribismo y por último la
pulverización del centro representado
por sergio
tiene su lugar entonces en este momento
a nuestro primer invitado del día él es
camilo granada analista político y
consultor de comunicaciones camilo
gracias por estar con nosotros en
derecho américa de france 24 buena
mañana del lunes un día post electoral
aquí en colombia y le pregunto entonces
que representa este resultado para los
partidos tradicionales qué lectura le
podemos dar a estos comicios
buenos días raúl muchas gracias por la
invitación
yo diría tres cosas la primera es que es
un es una demostración de los ganadores
son totalmente antisistema ambos
candidatos son opuestos al
establecimiento usted lo señalaba esta
es una derrota del establecimiento
político tradicional colombiano que ha
gobernado durante los últimos 70 años
y en particular del uribismo que ha sido
la fuerza preponderante y
decisiva a lo largo de las últimas dos
décadas pero no solamente con los
partidos tradicionales y el
establecimiento político también es un
rechazo en general al establecimiento
social y económico del país y la prueba
es que efectivamente tenemos dos
candidatos totalmente por fuera de esos
establecimientos el 1 columna con una
izquierda una propuesta de izquierda
radical de cambio bien conocida de
tiempo atrás y el otro un desconocido a
nivel nacional hasta hace muy poco
tiempo mayor que no hizo campaña
tradicional que no hizo grandes
reuniones en plaza pública
y que demuestra claramente que colombia
quiere un cambio el 70% de los electores
votó por una forma de cambio hacia un
lado o el otro pero por fuera del
establecimiento ahora camino le pregunto
qué pasará con esos codiciados votos por
estos candidatos que van al balotaje
hablamos por supuesto de los casi 5
millones de votos que obtuvo federico
gutiérrez y hacia dónde se van a ir y
también la pregunta es si finalmente
rodolfo hernández va a aceptarlo
públicamente digamos que esos votos de
un establecimiento digamos de un partido
de establecimiento y una campaña de
federico gutiérrez vayan a su campaña
por el balotaje
pero yo creo que es la decisión
hoy en día en colombia el ganador de el
próximo 19 de junio de las elecciones
presidenciales será quien logre generar
menos miedo romper el nivel de
incertidumbre que generan sus propuestas
tanto bien sea por ser de cambio de
izquierda radical o por la simple y mera
incertidumbre del desconocimiento de lo
que contiene en sus propios y el tipo de
gobierno que sería que en el caso del
ingeniero rodolfo fernández 3 quien
logre reducir los miedos quien logre
tranquilizar al electorado respecto del
tipo de cambio y cómo va a liderar al
país en los próximos cuatro años será el
ganador entonces en ese sentido pues
aunque pareciera que buena parte de los
electores de federico gutiérrez son
también ante todo anti petistas y el
miedo que puede generar
rodolfo hernández no significa que no va
a tener todos los votos de la derecha
con él porque hay mucha gente que le
tiene miedo a la incertidumbre que trae
rodolfo hernández entonces en la campaña
se va a centrar el como le doy más
confianza a los electores respecto del
cambio que viene porque cambio ahora
ahora yo no creo para responder su
pregunta de raúl yo no creo que
rodolfo hernández tenga que aceptar a
nadie formalmente el seguramente no se
va a reunir con federico gutiérrez no se
va a reunir con los expresidentes no se
va a reunir con las electas de partido
porque no lo necesita porque él tiene en
su propio caudal en
esos casi seis miles de votos
actualmente y generará un atractivo para
los que quieren frenar a toda costa a
petro natural sin necesidad de hacer
alianzas formales con ningún partido que
ningún partido queda en posición de
negociar su apoyo a ninguno de los dos
candidatos presidenciales que siguen en
el balotaje camino en ese sentido
recordemos ayer un poco el discurso que
dio rodolfo hernández un discurso bien
apaciguado leyó su discurso digamos que
estaría entendiendo entonces ese
discurso moderado que tiene que tener de
ahora en adelante para poder ganar esta
segunda vuelta en las elecciones y
también como vio el mensaje y el
discurso que dio gustado pero tras la
victoria en la primera vuelta
pero que el discurso del golfo es un
clásico muy bien pensado discurso de
primera vuelta el ganador
agradeció a sus electores y se mantuvo
muy en línea muy coherente con su
discurso inicial el solo hecho de que
como usted lo señalaba lo dio su
discurso leído pero desde era desde él
desde la cocina de su casa de campo
cerca de bucaramanga no en una sede de
campaña no en un hotel
sin bombas y sin sentido alrededor él
solo en la cocina de su casa es muy
consistente con el cambio que quiere
señalar es esto es distinto a todo lo
demás soy distinto a la política
tradicional soy distinta a los políticos
que ustedes han conocido a lo largo de
los años y soy el cambio en el discurso
de gustavo petro me pareció un poco
defensivo y hay una paradoja interesante
que me muestra presente esa carrera por
vencer el miedo como fórmula para ganar
si es que petro centró su discurso de
primera vuelta en atacar a rodolfo como
presente el cambio que es un salto al
vacío mientras que él sería
paradójicamente ese cambio responsable
mesurado y seguro que hasta
las elecciones de ayer él no era el que
representaba entonces hay en su discurso
también paradójico y lo hizo desde el
hotel tequendama que son el salón rojo
que se llama el hotel tequendama que es
uno de los sitios más emblemáticos de la
política tradicional en colombia donde
se han hecho todos los discursos de
victoria a buena parte de los discursos
de victoria o derrota de los políticos
tradicionales en los últimos 40 años en
colombia entonces estaba en un sitio muy
tradicional en un formato muy
tradicional y con un discurso que
buscaba tranquilizar mientras que
rodolfo se mantuvo en su discurso corto
sencillo y muy
espontáneo entre trabillas
y muy coherente consigo mismo